fernanda lee un artículo en el cual
mencionan que el 26 por ciento de los
estadounidenses pueden hablar más de un
idioma a ella le da curiosidad saber si
esta cantidad es mayor en su ciudad por
lo que hay aprobó su hipótesis nula que
dice que la proporción de personas en su
ciudad es la misma que la de todos los
estadounidenses 26 por ciento y en su
hipótesis alternativa la proporción en
su ciudad es mayor al 26 por ciento
donde p representa la proporción de
personas en su ciudad que pueden hablar
más de un idioma encontró que 40 de las
120 personas muestreadas pueden hablar
más de un idioma lo que ocurre aquí es
que tenemos la población de la ciudad y
ella toma una muestra de la población el
tamaño de la muestra es de 120 personas
calcula la proporción muestral que es 40
sobre 120 que es igual a un tercio y que
es aproximadamente igual a 0.33 el
estadístico de prueba para estos
resultados fue z aproximadamente igual a
1.83 hemos hecho esto en otros vídeos
pero para recordar cómo se obtiene esto
recuerden que cuando hacemos estas
pruebas de significante
suponemos que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera y luego calculamos cuál es la
probabilidad de que tengamos algo que
tenga este valor al menos en este
extremo o más allá y si se encuentra por
debajo de cierto valor que fijamos de
antemano
entonces rechazamos la hipótesis nula y
sospechamos la validez de la hipótesis
alternativa a esto se refiere este
estadístico z cuantas desviaciones
estándar por arriba de la proporción
supuesta se encuentra esto para el
estadístico z tenemos que encontrar la
diferencia entre lo que encontramos en
nuestra proporción muestral y la
proporción verdadera que suponemos 0.33
menos 0.26 todo esto entre la desviación
estándar de la distribución muestral de
la proporción muestral en vídeos
anteriores vimos que esto es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de la proporción supuesta
la proporción supuesta de la población
por uno menos la proporción supuesta de
la población entre n en esta situación
particular esto es igual a 0.26 por uno
menos 0.26 entre 120 y si resolvemos
esto nos debe dar como
aproximado 1.83 en este problema ya no
se ahorraron todo este trabajo
finalmente nos dicen que suponiendo que
se cumplen las condiciones necesarias
esto se refiere a que se cumplen las
condiciones necesarias para suponer que
la distribución muestral de esta
proporción muestral tiene forma
aproximadamente normal es decir que se
cumplen las condiciones de aleatoriedad
de independencia y la condición normal
de las que hemos hablado anteriormente
cuál es el valor que ha aproximado el
valor p será igual a la probabilidad de
que suponiendo que la distribución
muestra 'la sea normal tengamos un valor
de zeta mayor o igual a 1.83 para
visualizar esto imaginen que tenemos una
distribución normal y la media de la
distribución muestral es la proporción
supuesta de la población o la proporción
supuesta que viene de la hipótesis nula
de sub 0 que es igual a 0.26 y el
resultado que tenemos de la muestra está
a 1.83 desviaciones estándar por arriba
de la media de la distribución muestral
así que está más o menos por acá así que
esta probabilidad es
esta área bajo la curva normal ahora
veamos la tabla zeta esta tabla nos da
el área bajo la curva a la izquierda de
cierto valor z pero nosotros queremos el
valor a la derecha de cierto valor z
sin embargo recuerden que una
distribución normal es simétrica así que
en lugar de buscar algo que sea mayor o
igual a 1.83 desviaciones estándar por
arriba de la media vamos a buscar algo
que sea menor a 1.83 desviaciones
estándar por debajo de la media esto es
menos 1.83 buscamos este valor en la
tabla zeta y encontramos este valor cero
punto cero 336 así que esto es
aproximadamente igual a cero punto cero
336 o un poco más del 3% y menos del 4%
así que fernanda va a comparar esto con
el nivel de significancia que ella
definió antes de hacer esta prueba de
significancia si por ejemplo su nivel de
significancia fuera 5% entonces ya que
este resultado es menor que el nivel de
significancia rechazará la hipótesis
nula ella dirá que la probabilidad
de tener este resultado suponiendo que
la hipótesis nula es verdadera se
encuentra debajo del valor que determine
y rechazará la hipótesis nula y
sospechar a la validez de la alternativa
por otra parte si el nivel de
significancia es menor que este valor
entonces ella no rechazará la hipótesis
nula nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo